- I'm just recording this vertically
just because I know what I'm about to say
and I just want to document,
like it's so obvious
to me what's going to happen
with DailyVee and Snapchat.
Like, our execution these next 12 months,
it's going to be so fucking crazy
what it all looks like a year from today.
Like, maybe you'll use this video
to show the numbers.
As a matter of fact,
make sure you document
my youtube subscribers and,
I'll save right now a Snapchat story,
how many story views I'm getting.
And we'll literally run this video,
put it in your calendar right now.
A year from today we will put this out
because what a lot of
people don't understand
is it's execution, and we put the
pieces in place of full execution, right?
- [DRock] Yep.
- Oh, and there's one other thing.
Pure talent.
And you, DRock, are talented.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- But I, I, but I--
- [DRock] I knew that was coming.
- Yeah, you knew.
- But I, I am really talented.
(intense music)
- [DRock] Hey hey.
- DailyVee zero zero three.
I'm rapping in this, am I?
So all about the Snapchat.
Like, I just, the attention is so dope.
You're really doing well.
- Thank you.
Yeah, it's going great.
And it's feeding to like website traffic,
email interaction,
pushing application scale.
- Oh, you mean it works?
How weird.
- Snapchat.
I'm in, as of today, just like
- Just like the weights?
- Fitness got me into Snapchat.
I've been doing vlog answers--
- But you know what I mean, right?
- Yeah, I'm gonna hire
my own videographer.
- No, don't DRock it.
- No, I'm gonna do it.
I'm going hard.
And then I'll get myself a Mike.
- Get a Mike and a DRock
if you want to live life.
(laughs)
One thing I've learned from
having a relationship with Laz
is as I'm getting older I want to do
business with people that I like.
I think in your 20s and 30s you're just
trying to make it happen.
I think when you start getting into
a different place in your career,
to me, he's one of the best dudes.
Like anything he would ever want to do,
I would want to be involved in and so,
I just think
getting to that place where you're
just doing business with people
you actually, genuinely
like is the holy grail.
Morning, how are you?
Car's going to airport.
15 minutes, you have 20 minutes?
I mean if the car's there,
we gotta try and get in something tight.
Yes, yes, okay, okay bye.
DRock.
- [Voiceover] Yep.
- Get in here.
I mean, we've got to
show people that I shower
or they'll think I smell, DRock.
This is what happens when I
pack and Lizzie doesn't pack.
She says, you've got everything?
And I'm like yeah babe, got it all.
Except socks.
(phone rings)
- [Voiceover] This is Brielle.
- Brielle, it's Gary
Vaynerchuk, how are you?
- [Brielle] Good, how are you?
- Super well.
The thing that I'm most
fascinated in watching
is that people are blown away that there's
no natural discovery
within a Snapchat world.
You have to use other channels
to really get your exposure,
and so taking a step
back in 2016 if you're
one of the biggest brands in the world,
thinking about how you're going
to use your website,
your email, your packaging,
your Facebook, your
Instagram, your advertising
in other places to drive
a following on Snapchat
using Snapchat influencers,
other things of that nature,
and then having a creative strategy
within it for your stories?
That's the number one thing
people should be doing.
But what I think you know that I also know
is there is not a single
company that is ready
to allocate hundreds of
thousands of dollars in creative
just against a Snapchat
story five days a week,
seven days a week, 365 days a year.
Full throttle, you know
500,000, one million
dollars, two million
dollars in production fee
to be the best brand on Snapchat
by putting out a compelling story
which consists of seven videos and
three pictures every 24 hours of the day.
- [Brielle] Mhmm.
Yeah, I totally agree with that statement.
Now how do you feel, 'cause
I've seen a lot of brands
try and really try to
get you to their site,
to their Snapchat account,
but how do you kind of, how do you feel
that people can actually make that happen?
Like how do you think that, you know,
it's not just me looking at your username
and going, oh, maybe.
Like how can you actually
get me to add your name?
- You know, I think that's
a tremendous question.
I think every brand has to have its own
kind of content strategy.
I think a lot of brands are gonna go
for the lowest common denominator
which is, they're gonna run contests
or follow us on, you know, on Snapchat
and blah blah blah will happen and you
can win a free trip or a
free this, or da da da da da.
What I think the right thing to do is
make an incredible story and then
download a piece of it, right?
And then upload it on your other channels
so that when people see it in a tweet
or in a Facebook post, or in
an Instagram 15 second clip,
they get so excited about
well what else is there?
It compels them to go follow it.
The content is always king.
You know, we say that in marketing
all the time, it's super
cliche, the problem is
most people don't execute on it.
And so, instead of doing a cheap move
just to get as many views
on your story as possible
by giving stuff away or incentivizing it,
I say make great quality content.
Use your other social
vehicles and other digital
and even traditional vehicles,
to share that content
and then compel people to come and watch.
- [Brielle] I completely agree.
Like the Royals, things
like that I really like
the way that that happened.
I know that you guys--
- Yeah we worked on it.
Yeah, and that's how
we think about things.
We're religious.
The one thing about
VaynerMedia when I started it
six years ago is we are religious about
storytelling properly on the platform.
So what we put on Facebook isn't gonna
be what we put on
Snapchat, blah blah blah.
But, when we're trying
to build something up,
we don't mind using some of the
other channels as distribution for,
like my example for
Snapchat, to build that base
and then we go back to going
native and really driving success.
- [Brielle] That's a great strategy.
Definitely gives me a lot to work with.
I think I can definitely make a
really great article from all this.
Thank you so much for all your insight.
- Of course.
Hope you have a great, great, 2016.
Talk to you soon.
- [Brielle] You too!
- A big idea.
You know how DJ Khaled has uh...
- [DRock] Yeah, his--
- Boomin'?
- [DRock] Yeah, Boomin'.
- I want you to say yep to everything.
- [DRock] Yep.
- Just want to give a huge
shoutout on my DailyVee
to Nicholas Megalis, one
of the most talented,
I don't know if you can get in here DRock,
get in here 'cause he
just got me super pumped.
He gave me a shoutout on his snap.
One of the great viners and
one of the great talents I know
and just way more importantly,
one of the best dudes you'll ever meet.
So google Nicholas, or actually
DRock, we can edit here.
M-E-G-A-L-I-S, Megalis,
real talent, real talent.
Just a great dude, thanks Nicholas.
DRock, we don't have to cam.
I mean, it's not a
fucking reality TV show.
I hope you don't like call the
episode like, where's my gel?
Ah, found it.
Hi Misha and Xander, it's Daddy.
I love you guys.
I miss you.
And thank you so much for all your videos.
(kiss noise)
Have the best day!
I'll talk to you soon.
Mommy will FaceTime with us later.
I love you.
(kissing noises)
Long before it was cool, I
myself was an entrepreneur
getting Ds and Fs in everyone's face
as a 13, 14, 15-year-old.
In your face, DRock.
I miss Alfalfa.
This Alfalfa's legit.
You know what?
I might bring that back.
- [DRock] Umm.
- You don't think people, what?
SS that fires me up
big, thank you so much.
(people murmuring)
Hi, nice to meet you.
- Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Such a pleasure.
How are you?
- So what we're thinking--
- Oh, I do a daily vlog.
Don't worry, no audio.
Oh, it's here?
Awesome, yeah it's upstairs.
Amazing.
That was fun.
It's always fun when you think you
gotta go travel and
it's the same building.
I'm just gonna catch up with some email.
- [DRock] Yep.
(murmuring)
See ya.
Stay well.
- Oh hey Gary.
- How are ya?
- [Woman] I'm well, how are you?
- Good to see you.
- [Woman] Yeah you too.
- Are you Gary?
- I am.
- I'm Carly.
It is so nice to meet you.
- Everyone's eating?
- Everyone's eating.
- So I can literally, I'm great.
I can set up and just like, thank you.
A lot of you ask me how I
keep my phone charged.
Ghetto style.
Hi Katie.
- [Katie] Hi!
- How are you?
- [Katie] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
It's good to see you.
- It's so good to see you, I miss you!
- I miss you too, how are you?
- Pretty good.
- So whether you're in
fitness or in social media
or in insurance, people are
gonna want to talk about what...
Only so much time.
So whether you're in
insurance, social media,
sports, fishing, people
are gonna want to know
what it means to your industry
now that Snapchat is on.
And if you're watching this, it means
that you're starting to pay attention
to what's going on on Snapchat.
You want to hear my thoughts on it.
You're getting curious about
what you should do on it.
Right now, the only thing I've been
talk about in the world is Snapchat.
I don't care about anything else.
I only care about it
because I haven't seen
this much attention to content
and engagement since very early 2007
and eight, Twitter, right?
Just from a pure organic standpoint,
if you have 1,000 people
following your stories
you have 900 of them
who actually consume it.
And so you play the game where
everybody talks about reach.
Having visitors, how many this,
how many that.
Reach has nothing to do
with actually selling shit.
- You wanna do it here, or
do you wanna go to the...
- Hi, come in here.
- Finding my theme song.
- What are you gonna rap?
- Gotta find a theme song.
- I'm turning into a 14-year-old girl.
And that's why I'm so into you.
You did it.
You're only playing practical and truths.
I seem crazy as fuck, I'm only practical.
- [Woman] No, we're not
afraid to do the fucking work.
- Well that put me--
- What are you planning--
- Oh, you have two things.
- Yeah.
- God, it looks so much better now, man.
When did you take that picture?
- This one was recent.
- No this one.
- This one was like, a month ago.
- You're just fucking rolling now.
- You like any of these?
- No.
- No, I'll go with that,
with my face on the book?
They don't like it.
They don't want me to put
my face on the book though.
- They're wrong.
Because you know that
you don't give a fuck.
- So the other thing--
- You know that that's
more valuable than like,
like your face on the book is the
most valuable part of the whole thing.
- Yeah, yeah, all right boom.
So that, the other thing is so...
- [Gary] See you guys later.
- [DRock] Bye guys.
- [Woman] Have a great day!
- [DRock] You too.
- India, I'll give you the copy.
India, with the, you got this?
India with the bump.
- I haven't been to Canada for
ten days since I moved here.
Now I'm like, feel behind already.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Hope you had a good--
- Here, handshake again.
- No, no, no, it's fine.
(people murmuring)
- [Man] Hey.
- Hello.
- [Man] How are you?
- What's going on, man?
Good to see you.
- Speaking of which,
Snapchat stories,
- Yes.
- And I'm telling you right now,
for the first time in a long time
I'm obsessed with it.
I think it's the biggest opportunity.
I think you guys could really
change your business by doing this.
The growth potential is enormous.
It's fully being consumed.
My Twitter has never been more
on fire than it is right now.
In seven years, uh-huh, 'cause
you can't talk here except one-on-one.
You can only publicize, so
there's a crossover there.
This, when people hit you up,
and you talk to them, and you say this?
They're reacting the way Twitter reacted.
The way I put my brand?
- Do you guys want to order some food?
- It's a real moment.
You know, look, I'm the guy that
fucking flew Jerome Jarre, right?
To Ashton three days after he was in,
like I know these things.
I know these things.
This right now is at the right spot.
Literally six months ago it wasn't.
It was still too peer-to-peer.
It was still too young.
It's time.
And everybody by this time
next year is gonna do it,
and having that year is gonna matter.
If it was me, I'm about to put
a lot of celebrities on it.
Like Kim Kardashian's about to go on.
DJ Khaled just put pictures
of her and said coming soon
and it's Kim Kardashian with him.
Like, it's about to get crazy.
Honestly, in a different way, DJ Khaled
is the Ashton Kutcher moment for Twitter.
Ooh, that was good.
Did you get that?
- [DRock] I did.
Good, it's good to have you around.
You know what would be amazing?
A startup that could literally
transcribe every word
and make everything searchable.
You just upload it to drives
and like, didn't I say?
Oh.
- [DRock] I would love that so much.
- It's coming, in 15 years.
- How are ya?
Good to see you.
I won't interrupt, you guys.
- Two minutes.
- Yeah do your thing.
- Thanks bud.
So my first Snapchat mission is with
my amazing business partners at Brave
who are the brightest minds in the
TV tech infrastructure world ever.
They're setting it up now.
My amazing business partners at Brave
who are the brightest minds in the
TV tech infrastructure world ever.
You're in?
So make your first one
so I can press share.
What's that?
- What's up?
- Snapchat is fucking got my mind.
- Watch it spin.
It's the funniest thing ever.
Just spins out.
- Nothing will happen right?
- Nothing will happen.
- Can I take a picture of
this and just talk to them?
- Yes.
- Can I talk to them about
it just for a second?
- I am finally back on Snapchat.
After all this time, I can actually log in
crazy enough, because of this guy GaryVee.
- What's up?
- Make sure to follow my boy.
Happy to be back.
I will be snapping away here soon guys.
Talk to you guys.
- That's Kevin J?
- Jonas, J-O-N-A-S-I-I.
- I-I?
- Yep.
Like that.
- Yes.
- Can I show you another little trick?
- Love you bro.
- Be good, I'll see you soon.
- [Gary] I'll see you in a little bit.
- Catch you later.
- All right, talk to you soon.
- [Kevin] Thanks for hanging out.
- Yeah, thanks.
So DRock is who films the Ask GaryVee show
and has historically,
but you've seen the first
one or two DailyVees?
- [Erik] Yeah, there were just two, right?
- You're about to be in the third one.
We're doing it right now.
- Awesome.
- So, Erik's working on a article.
- How are you liking CES?
- Good, it's been productive.
I mean, I love any event that brings
a lot of my contacts into one place.
I've gotten 11 meetings that
would take me seven weeks
and three planes to accomplish, today!
Like I don't know how deep we're gonna go.
If you go read the
comments on episode two?
- Right.
- There were people that
basically said things
like I've been watching
you for three years,
hearing you for three years.
I didn't get how hard you actually worked.
- Yeah.
- So I think one of, I
think I'm living a life
that is an anomaly.
That I wish I documented
all my truths to this level
because all the people that
think I was smart about
Twitter, they don't even know how much.
And I think this will do that.
That we're capturing my
conversation about Snapchat
right now and in 18 months when Snapchat
is literally the only other
main platform in the world,
as big as big gets,
I'll have this narrative
on how right I was on
its mainstream ability
while so many people in this hotel
still think that it's
for kids or dick pics.
- One more time.
- This is gonna allow me to give away
an enormous amount of free advice.
- Right.
- Whereas I could not
do this, charge every--
Do you know how many people
of tomorrow I announce?
I am no longer putting out contacts.
I am creating the Gary Vaynerchuk
school of mastermind of marketing.
And it is $5,000 a month to
get what you've been getting.
Do you know how much money I would make?
Tens of millions of dollars.
And that's what most people do.
- [Erik] So why aren't you?
- Because I have this
equal ambition to succeed.
Because I think I have
enough talent to do both.
That's why.
Snapchat, I'm obsessed with it right now.
- What's going on with Snapchat?
- It's about to win the attention graph.
- About to be attention graph?
- You, you, how old are you?
- How old am I?
46.
- You, at 48 years old, are
gonna consume on Snapchat.
- Okay.
- That's why I'm excited.
- Interesting. Why, why is it?
What's it got going for
it that nothing else has?
- The scale of 13 to
27-year-olds that will
educate the 28 to 60-year-olds
to the value prop over time.
- Okay.
- Like Facebook.
- Yeah, okay, that's cool.
But then those kids will
move on to something else.
- That's right, not those same kids,
'cause they'll become the
generation of Snapchat.
- Right, right, the new generation.
- Uh-huh.
- What do you think's on the horizon--
- There's so much good stuff here, DRock.
And this is where everybody else loses.
The people that are not
doing it the right way.
- [Erik] Right.
- I'm not playing you like
a violin because I'm putting
in the work to make you
say yes to the second part.
- [Erik] Absolutely, I totally get that.
- You're welcome.
Short doors.
- It's so funny you say that
'cause I was about to be like
yo, wanna get our annual drink at CES...
- How are you doing?
- Great, man.
Good to see you man.
Good to have the same place.
- Yeah, how you been man?
Doing well, right?
- Doing great, man.
- You're in nice things.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah, you gotta come in though.
We gotta get you in.
Give me two minutes, okay?
- [Voiceover] Well sometimes
they don't like that.
- [Gary] I totally get it.
- [DRock] Yeah, that's cool.
- There you go.
- Oh, it's upstairs.
Got it.
- [Voiceover] It's upstairs.
- I'll text you.
Can I text him and say Ben it's okay
and he can show you, or do
you want me to come down?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, you can text him.
- Okay cool, I'll let you know.
No, I'm just getting, it's for the vlog.
- Okay.
- [Gary] I'm going vertical.
Notice how I'm holding the phone.
- [Voiceover] I was gonna say...
- [Gary] By the way, I'm
doing this on Snapchat.
It's fucking with people, it's working.
I'm hacking your system.
This Snapchat ice sculpture
at the Snapchat dinner
is maybe my favorite thing
I've seen in a long time.
A long time.
How you doing, DRock?
- [DRock] I'm good, how are you?
- Good man, all right, what are we doing?
DRock, you love that?
- [DRock] Oh yeah.
- Is that gonna make DailyVee?
This, this...
This daily vlog thing is
gonna be such a big deal.
- [DRock] Why do you say that?
- Why do you say that?
(laughs)
Just put that part there.
Number one piece of advice for
all of you that are joining Snapchat,
which is quite a few of you.
What's up, Sam T?
And what about this guy?
Ben Benrubi.
What a name.
Anyway, number one piece of advice:
google how to use Snapchat.
Allocate 20 minutes.
Read, watch a couple Youtube videos.
It will help so many of you so much
because it is a different language.
- I was in DailyVee one.
- [Gary] Were you?
- Yeah, it was the basketball one.
- Oh basketball, that's really good.
- It was the day you hit that shot.
- You're gonna end up, you're right.
That's gonna end up being a real fun fact
'cause this thing is gonna be fire.
- I hope so.
How you doing, DRock?
- [DRock] I'm good. How are you?
- I'm great.
Happy to be in Vegas.
(chattering)
- Snapchat now!
- It's true, I'm very serious.
- What's the fucking shit on Snapchat?
- All right, going into this.
This wraps it up, huh?
- [DRock] Yep.
- You want me to send you some
video of my other meetings?
- [DRock] Yep.
- You're gonna be editing in the room?
- See you later.
Okay, so out of the MediaLink party
and instead of going to some meetings,
I think I'm going to go back
to my room and answer some--
A lot of young entrepreneurs asking me
what advice I'd give them
and my answer is patience,
because you have a lot of time to get it.
(dramatic music)